we've got to get to cryptocurrencies
which are in the midst of a meltdown
yeah you could call it that Bitcoin nose
diving below 23 000 this morning and
right now hovering just above 23 000 at
23 271. it's lowest since December of
2020. now ethereum has lost two-thirds
of its value this year we do have ether
down 457 points that's a loss of 27
percent Litecoin xrp they are getting
stampeded here the value of the entire
crypto Market has now fallen below one
trillion dollars now the crypto collapse
arguably started over the weekend but
seriously accelerated Sunday when
digital currency lending company Celsius
Network which has close to 2 million
accounts worth about 20 billion Froze
all withdrawals and transfers on the
platform due to what it called quote
extreme conditions the halt an ensuing
alarm caused a domino effect across the
digital currency ecosystem and then the
situation worsened this morning would
binance the world's largest crypto
exchange suddenly blocked all Bitcoin
withdrawals for about an hour CEO Shang
Pang Zhao said that the pause was caused
by a quote stuck transaction which
triggered a backlog on the network now
this spreads to the crypto Universe
right contagion darkened immediately at
the open microstrategy whose CEO Michael
Saylor is a huge crypto investor is
taking a beating right now down 28.6
percent the company has lost one billion
dollars over its nearly 130 000 Bitcoin
bet and is down 70 percent year-to-date
coinbase this is the largest crypto
trading platform in the U.S fell as low
as 46 dollars it's at 50 now 50 and
change but still down 13 percent we've
got Bitcoin miners marathon and digital
Holdings Riot blockchain plunging in the
red but one of bitcoin's biggest names
says we're not there yet but he believes
we are getting close to a quote
generational buying opportunity joining
me now on a fox business exclusive pump
Investments Anthony pompliano first let
me get to this pump what do you believe
is at the heart of this sell-off
yeah look it's very obvious that the
Federal Reserve is in control right now
and in many cases all assets are just
one big trade at the moment uh and so if
you go ahead and you take a look going
all the way back to uh the beginning of
2020. going back to January 1st 2020
with hindsight uh kind of on your side
and you could buy any asset you would
have bought Bitcoin and outperform
stocks bonds real estate Commodities
other currencies Etc but that doesn't
mean that it is in any way insulated
from the macro environment and I think
what we're watching right now is the
transfer of Bitcoin from weak short-term
uh oriented people uh with weak hands
into the long-term oriented strong hands
and you see that on chain uh with the
various wallet metrics but you also see
it with a lot of Wall Street firms uh
seeming to dump Bitcoin that they got
into over the last you know eight to 12
months and you see a lot of the uh
people have been around for a long time
saying hey I've been here before I've
seen this happen and I got a really long
time Horizon and this is really
attractive this let me let me drill down
here so the institutional guys along
with some of the marginal people you
know people on the side who had a couple
of Bitcoin they are getting extremely
anxious or maybe pom they are driven by
the fact that they've lost a lot of
money in the stock market and they need
to raise cash and they're doing it by
exiting Bitcoin
I think there's two ways to look at this
right first is if you look at the
institutional folks uh Bitcoin began to
get institutionalized uh and Bitcoin is
the riskiest thing in their portfolio
and so if they're going to go risk off
they sell Bitcoin and they happen to
have a lot of Bitcoins they have a lot
of money in their portfolios and so
Bitcoin started to uh dump just like
every other uh risk asset uh went down
as well over the last eight months now
one of the things to pay attention to
and what I think a lot of people that
are more Bitcoin native uh or have been
around for a while we are watching a
Divergence price and value are
completely decoupling right now for
Bitcoin what I mean by that is price is
down from 69 000 high in November uh
down to around twenty three thousand
dollars today but hashary hit an
all-time high today the Bitcoin network
has never been more secure than it is
today if you then go take a look at the
Bitcoin wallet addresses with 0.01
Bitcoin 0.1 Bitcoin or one Bitcoin in
them those all three have hit all-time
highs and the lightning network capacity
also is hitting an all-time high okay
and so in some way that decoupling is
the fundamental mentals continue to hit
all-time highs and strengthen while
price is falling and I think that at
some point fundamentals uh and kind of
the value of Bitcoin will meet price the
question is where and when that happens
right so Twain shell meet is what you're
saying uh we also got a bit of worry
some news from block five this of course
is a crypto exchange and wallet company
and they're the ones they have these
interest bearing accounts they announced
that they are trimming their head count
by 20 they said that it would basically
affect everybody at the company this is
all a lot of bad news and that said you
feel that we're getting close to a
buying opportunity at least in Bitcoin
we're at twenty three thousand one
eighty seven uh talking to somebody
who's skeptical here
I I think there's two different things
there's Bitcoin then there's the
equities in in the uh uh industry and
I'm an investor in blackfy so I don't
want to comment specifically on that
business uh but I think across the
industry what you're seeing is that
these are still businesses where there's
cash flows and there's balance sheets
and they have to run businesses for the
long term uh and so naturally as you
head towards what many people deem to be
a bad time in the macro economic
environment you're going to get folks
looking and saying how do we Shore up
our balance sheet how do we get to uh
profitability that's not a Bitcoin or
crypto thing that's across all
technology industry now when it comes to
bitcoin specifically I think ultimately
the value investor framework is being
applied to bitcoin by bitcoiners and
that kind of puts a lot of uh the the
Legacy Finance folks their heads go into
a blender when that occurs because you
take the Timeless principles Warren
Buffett buy great assets and hold them
forever okay that's the price where
you'll say it's a generational buying
opportunity
historically when Bitcoin trades below
the realized price or the on-chain cost
basis uh that tends to be a pretty good
chance we're there now who knows how
much lower it could go or if it goes
sideways or even has a strong recovery
but I think that there's a lot of
bitcoiners who are saying I'm buying an
asset where the price has dislocated
from the value or the fundamentals and
just like those value investors would do
that with traditional businesses the
bitcoiners are salivating right now and
you see them gobbling up as much of that
Bitcoin as possible
it's not moving the price though still
uh pretty pretty dramatically lower here
at the moment let's just do a final
check as we continue to watch all of
this and more we do have Bitcoin down
about 20.6 percent uh Anthony great to
see you thank you for coming on on a
very major news day especially in the
crypto space
absolutely thanks for having me listen